- Mo Williams literally left.
Nobody knew where he went.
And then came back and played
in Game 5 of the NBA Finals—
- Yeah.
- And was important to us.
Dahntay Jones played
in the Finals.
Like, I remember vividly Coach
going, "Dahntay, I need you."
And he rips his stuff off.
Hasn't played a minute.
- Dahntay Jones was
big for Game 6.
- Intregal.
Is that the word?
- He was—
- Intregal.
- Integral. There we go.
That's a good word.
In-tre-gal.
♪♪♪
What up, guys?
Today, welcome to "Full-Bodied"
with my sorta good friend,
Kevin Love.
As the wines get
darker, the questions
are gonna get deeper.
Let's first open this Moet up.
I got this Moet, honestly, because I'm
pretty proud of you, man.
This is, what, Year 14?
- I'll be heading
into 14 next year.
- You know, we gotta
celebrate each year.
- I love it.
- This year has been
wild, to say the least.
Let's start like this.
Like, growing up in Lake
Oswego, Oregon,
like, when did you discover that
basketball was your thing?
Didn't you play baseball too?
- Played baseball,
played Little League.
I was a pitcher.
But, you know, my true love
was with basketball.
My dad played in the NBA.
- Right.
- Looked up to my dad
as my hero.
He had me on the phone
when I was young with, you know, guys
like Connie Hawkins.
He showed me Jerry West,
who he played with.
Gail Goodrich. Happy Hairston.
Elmore Smith, blocked
17 shots in a game.
Elvin Hayes. Earl the
Pearl. Wes Unseld,
who I'm named after—
my middle name, Wesley.
Some of the greatest
of all time.
So basketball was always it.
- Being there for
14 years—there's
a lotta guys,
actually, from Portland—
- Yeah.
- Who are just hoopers,
like Terrence Ross.
That was like—
I saw him play.
I was like, "This kid has no
business being in high school.
Like, he has no business—
like, he's a pro.
You can see it right there."
So your transition from
high school to UCLA—
like, why UCLA?
What was it about that
stupid school that you liked?
And also, what was it like
playing with Russell Westbrook
in your stacked team?
And I think you guys may
or may not have won once,
but I don't know.
I didn't do the research.
But go ahead.
- Did you guys win a
national championship
when you were there?
- Uh, yeah, we did, because we had—
it's a better school.
So we had to let
somebody else win.
- Right, right. No, understood.
I ended up picking UCLA
because, going back
to my dad for a second,
Morningside High School.
My dad's assistant high
school coach was Jim Harrick.
So we started going to
the games. All my family
from Southern California,
we would go to Pauley Pavilion—
- Yeah, yeah. Old-school Pauley.
- And watch Jim Harrick
and those teams play.
It was amazing to
see because, you know, there
was great pros
throughout the Pac-10.
And I always thought it'd be
great to play close to home—
- Right, right.
- Or close to family.
And my top two schools
at the end of the day
were North Carolina,
which is crazy.
Roy Williams—I mean,
finally, yeah, he hung it up.
- Yeah.
- It's crazy he—
after all that time.
So those were my
top two schools.
For me, it made the most sense.
Two back-to-back Final Fours,
and we ended up making it
to a third straight Final Four.
Lost to Memphis, which,
all four No. 1 seeds.
Kansas and North
Carolina were in there.
And that was an incredible year
but didn't get the job done.
Russ and I left, and we were
the fourth and fifth pick.
- Did you see the evolution
of Russell Westbrook
from then, who was just
this, like, downhill runner, just
attacking the rack, to this guy
that's now completely, like, crushing
the NBA?
- So it was crazy.
Russ and I, we had
known each other.
And I know he had come
from Leuzinger High School.
He didn't dunk till he was
a junior in high school.
- What?
- Which is crazy.
His senior year, Jordan Farmar
ended up going to the league,
so opened up a spot at UCLA.
- Yeah.
- I think his other school
might have been Creighton.
- Oh, wow.
- Russ ends up at UCLA.
Didn't play much.
I think maybe 11 minutes
his freshman year.
I remember watching him.
I think they played Kansas,
and he had a really great game.
But really just defensive
player, and then just
make some plays
happen on offense.
But he wasn't a primary focus
on either side of the ball.
So fast forward, the
summer when I got there.
The first time I saw
him in the men's gym—
and this was at the time when, like,
KG was in there, Paul Pierce.
Kobe would come in.
And I can remember
Russ just kinda taking it
off the top of the glass, you know,
coming down, surveying
the court, you know, kinda cross-grained
into the lane.
You know, kinda spun back and went
up with his left hand and was,
like, top of the
square and finished.
And I thought, "Wow.
He's gonna be special."
And the best thing, I
think, that happened to him,
and maybe even our team,
was that, unfortunately,
Darren Collison had an
MCL sprain in his knee.
Russell had to play point guard.
So he had to handle the ball.
He had to guide the team.
He had to run the team.
Once he moved to that
shooting guard position
and I was able to outlet
to both those guys,
those guys were able to, were all able
to play off each other—
Luc Mbah a Moute, Josh Shipp.
I mean, we had a number
of players on that team
that could really play.
- Good gracious.
That's a squad.
- That's a squad.
- We're at the Red Hook Winery.
And so this is an Abe Schoener
Jamesport Vineyard Sauvignon
Blanc.
They make a really good SB.
It has melon notes.
It's refreshing.
So we talked about
Russ' transformation.
We wanna talk about
your transformation, right?
You went from a big boy—
- Yeah, OK, OK. I thought you—
- With a full chinstrap
- Yep.
- To all of a sudden, you're
on, like, the ESPN "The Body Issue."
How was that evolution?
And then, like, you
were a walking bucket.
You were getting 20-and-20
as the old you,
but then your efficiency
was still there.
And a lotta guys can't do that.
- Yeah.
Well, first, I'll say this.
Like, I've had my fair share
of injuries in my career,
but I was looking at being
270 pounds and thinking that
wasn't sustainable—
- Right, right, right.
- At 6'8.5", like—
it just wasn't sustainable
for me to be that heavy.
I'm thinking, "I
can't play 82 games.
I can't play four
games in five nights.
I can't go play Dallas—"
- No.
- "Fly back and play
back-to-back being that heavy."
And I think I got away with it
because I was in my early 20s.
But I knew that long-term,
longevity-wise,
and being able to stay in
the league, especially with—
and my dad had the
presence of mind.
He's like, "You gotta
be able to shoot the ball.
- Yeah.
- "I know you have the touch.
I know you have the capability.
I know you have the skill set."
It was the same thing with
you being a stretch 5.
- Right, right.
- If you don't have that today,
you might not see the floor.
There's very few big men.
The post-ups are 50 percent down
in the last six years.
- Yeah.
I just think the
evolution of the game
is, like, there are more big
men that can shoot and stretch
the floor
- Yes.
- than there
are true point guards.
- No, and if you're able
to stretch the floor,
it's just such an
asset for a team,
especially knowing how hard
it is to guard those guys.
- Yeah.
- It's impossible.
But I think what my
father understood
and what I understood was
that the game was changing.
- Yeah, yeah. Oh, big time.
- And it was becoming a
pace-and-space type league.
- When I retired
from basketball, I
realized that wine was my
dream outside of the dream.
And I also realized
I had to do it
my way by creating my own wine
label, Chosen Family Wines.
And in this segment,
we're gonna dive
into my guest's dreams,
brought to you by Porsche.
So was there more pressure
being a lineage kid
than you think the
other kids—like, being, you know,
no offense, the white guy?
You're athletic, but you're
not, like, you don't jump out at
the gym.
Like, most of your highlight videos
were you throwing outlet passes.
- Right.
- And getting rebounds.
- [Laughing]
- Like, how does that, like, growing up that
way, how did that motivate you?
- I always talk about, like, we play
in the best league in the world
cuz it's so diverse.
Even dating back to my
childhood, my dad taking me,
having the presence of mind
and understanding cuz it
was the same way with him.
He grew up in
Inglewood, California,
went to Morningside
High School and played
against, you know, a lot of teams that
were predominantly Black.
- Right, right.
- And he knew that if he
was going to get better,
he had to play against the best.
- Right.
- And, you know, the league has been built on
the shoulders of Black players.
- Right.
- So he knew that taking myself—
and at the time, it was
Northeast Portland—injecting
me into, you know, Jefferson High
School, or Grant High
School, Lincoln High
School.
- Yeah, yeah.
- PIL schools
were in the inner
city. He said,
you have to play there
in order to get better.
It ended up being myself
and my best friend,
- Right.
Ernie Spada. Eventually
Kyle Singler,
who played in the league
for a number of years,
- Yeah, Kyle, comeback.
- Who, you know, were the only
white guys on the team.
- Yeah.
- And from that point
on, it just became, you know, kinda part
of who I am, what I'm about, is that,
you know, I knew if I was
gonna be the best,
I had to play against the best.
And that happened
to be the case.
You know, we're in such a
hypermasculine sport.
And it's both men
and women's
- Totally.
- Like, sports.
I really believe that.
Or it could be, you know, you
could work in finance.
You could work at a
Fortune 500 company.
Like, no matter what walk
of life you're in,
withholding compassion
does nobody any good.
Like, you're more empathetic,
you're more evolved,
you're a better listener, like,
it creates community.
It creates understanding.
So, I mean, that's what I've learned.
I'm, again, on the court, outside
of it, I'm not perfect at all.
I just hope, like, if I could
just help one kid, you know, early
intervention, get in
there and say, "Listen,
the brain is changing so
much" before behavior.
Like, if I can help that
one kid, listen, I'm good.
If I help myself,
I help somebody,
I'm living life out in the open,
I'm an open book, I'm good.
- Well, I think you've done that.
I think, what I thought
was, OK, well, I'm gonna
just deal with
this for this season,
and it's been ongoing, right?
There are times where I'm Mr.
Happy-Go-Lucky, to be honest.
I'm a glass-half-full dude.
But I feel like, you know, seeing
you guys, whether it's you
or DeMar DeRozan
or Dak Prescott,
I think more kids need
to be lifted up mentally.
A sport is not end-all, be-all.
Like, we, sometimes we forget.
Like, it's weird as an adult
who's played in the pros,
watching my son play and
then watch the other parents and
how they talk to their kid.
"You didn't," you know, "You didn't do this!"
And I'm like, "Hey, Hendrix,
did you get sweaty?"
I'm like, awesome, dude.
- [Laughing]
- Like, I don't care.
Like, are you enjoying your
time with your peers?
Are you understanding
the value of, like, camaraderie?
Sports should be an outlet and
a place where people can grow
and not a place
where you're supposed
to tuck your feelings away.
But something
awesome has happened.
And you see our whole lineup.
When I say our, I mean, you are
now part of the Chosen Family.
So let's talk about, like,
when did you get into wine?
Why did you want to get into
wine with me and with us
at Chosen?
- You know, I grew up just outside
of Portland, Oregon.
And obviously, if you've been
to Dundee Hills, Willamette
Valley, so on and so
forth in that region,
it's obviously become
more recognized as a place
where wine and that culture
is continuing to grow.
But when I was growing up, you know, it
was all pinot and chard grapes.
So that's what I was
first introduced to.
And it wasn't until my third
or fourth year in the league.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I came in at 19 years
old, started my rookie season
at 20.
But, yeah, my wine journey
continued really
through my aunt on
my dad's side who
introduced me to Napa cabs.
So she introduced me to a
lot of California grapes,
primarily being cabs.
So I initially just started
drinking a lot of cab.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I think, really, in 2015-16,
we started drinking that.
But then you came on the team.
- Yeah.
- We started bringing new bottles.
We started bringing
different shiraz.
We just started bringing
different pinots, chardonnays,
all across the board.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Italians, God...
- We were going old world, new world.
Exactly.
- Oh, good gracious.
- And I think that opened
me up to understanding
that, OK, the more I know, the
more I realize I don't know.
But boy, I love this.
This is, like you said, a
connector for so many people.
We would start bringing
it on the plane
and think, yo, why aren't
you giving me a glass?
Why can't I have a red
cup and drink this?
- Right, right.
- And we weren't snooty about, we
weren't snobby about it at all.
Then we would go to dinner.
- Oh, God.
- We would order more bottles.
- Yeah, oh.
- And you said it funny.
Like, you would do something, you know, super
obscure, something different.
You know, I would bring,
obviously, what I love,
which is mostly, like, cabs and stuff
that was heavy at the time.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Maybe some pinots
here and there.
That created a culture with us.
I think outside of
maybe Melo and a couple
other players, that
culture of wine
wasn't quite there
yet until, honestly, I
think we took it over
the top and started it.
- Yeah.
This has been a
long time coming.
We talked about it
before I retired.
- You know, we sat next to each
other on the plane.
If we wanted to start a
wine brand, first of all,
obviously, do it in Portland.
There's a storytelling
component there.
There's a family
Like, what would we name it?
So we started going through and
listing out different stuff.
You know, your parties at
the end of the year
- Oh, God.
- were all based around wine,
- Yeah.
- brought everybody together
collectively.
It was super cool.
And I loved what
yourself, Jake, Chase,
visiting L'Angolo,
visiting that area,
and starting Chosen Family.
I just, you guys were
doing something different
that I wanted to be a part of.
And it's funny we're
sitting here drinking wine,
because that, that all started
- Oh.
- once you got there.
And I'm talking about...
[Cork popping]
- Oh, it started.
- Yeah.
We didn't realize
exactly what we had.
What we had was so special.
Like, I look back, and
I think when you
reach the pinnacle, when you're
at the top, you want that.
It's like watching the
last, it's like a drug.
- Yeah.
- You want that.
And you want that
every single year.
So to come from a situation
like you were to come into that
and win a championship,
it's life-changing.
- Oh, for sure, it
was life-changing.
- It's a life-changing experience.
We were the most talented
underachieving regular-season
team of all time.
- Oh, easily.
- Without question.
We didn't care
until the playoffs.
- Did not care.
- No.
- We would lose
games and be like—
- Right.
- [Sighing] All right, what's next?
- Honestly, we were
"Days of our Lives."
- [Laughing]
- We had so many storylines.
We thrived under chaos.
But when it came
time, we had fun.
And we had the best time.
Like, it was the best—
I talked to Richard
about it last night,
best years of my life.
- Amen.
- Like, we have our group chat.
We talk every day.
- Every day.
- Every single day.
- My memories of Cleveland
were so vivid,
- Yeah.
- right?
And obviously, we won.
But, like, I've never been so locked
in with a team to where it
was like, we, like, loved each other.
Mo Williams literally
left, and nobody
knew where he went.
And then he came back
and played in Game
5 of the NBA Finals.
- Yeah.
- And was important to us.
Dahntay Jones played
in the Finals.
Like, I remember vividly Coach
going, "Dahntay, I need you."
And he rips his stuff off.
Hasn't played a minute.
- Dahntay Jones was big for us.
- Integral.
- Game 6.
- Integral, is that
the word, intregal?
- Integral.
There we go. That's a good word.
Mental health, right?
It has taken off.
And you have been the face.
You are the front of
the train of that.
So tell me what inspired
you to be the face of this
and then why you
are the way you are.
- Yeah.
Well, first of all, it
goes back to, really,
my childhood and
hiding it for, I mean,
really till I was 29 years old.
And that was 2017.
- Right.
- And not exposing it, actually,
till 2018. March of that year.
And it's funny.
You're such a huge part of it.
You know this, and a
lot of people don't, is
that there were a lot of pillars
that had fallen in my life
personally, whether it be my
family, friends, relationship,
business.
I started self-medicating.
I started getting
extremely dark.
The game was taken away from
me from an injury perspective.
I had broken my left hand
in a game in Detroit.
- Oh, I remember that.
- Yeah.
A lot of people didn't
know what was going on.
So I had teammates and people
turn on me and call me out,
and I wasn't ready to expose
myself at that level yet.
And then All-Star came around,
and Parkland, Florida, happened.
And there were
rumblings at All-Star
that were going on of certain
people trying to speak
about me and my mental health.
And I said, OK, now I
need to tell my story.
I don't want anybody
else to tell my story.
I need to take this
into my own hands.
I'm afraid.
I'm afraid of how
people are going
to react, how it's going to
affect my livelihood, what
people are gonna think,
what my best friends are
gonna think who don't
even know what the hell I’m
going through.
So that led me up to that point.
I didn't pull back
the curtain that much,
but enough for people
to look inside and say,
everybody is going
through something.
And us athletes
are no different.
Success is not
immune to depression.
This thing doesn't discriminate.
Look at the numbers, especially
coming out of this time too,
the last 12 to 14 months.
It’s just—
- When you see death for real,
or when you deal with that,
or when you're in
that place, you
can't justify putting
your energy into a game.
- Because honestly—
- I can't fight how I feel.
- Different context, but
it was a similar feeling.
That summer was very,
very, very dark for me.
- Yeah.
- I had people literally
saying, like,
“Don't take your life this summer.”
And that was crazy to me to
hear that, because I'm thinking,
maybe I have blinders on.
Maybe I'm not seeing what
these people are seeing.
So I really had to look
myself in the mirror,
had to look inward that
summer and work on myself.
But from then and earlier
that year to where I am now,
I feel like being able to
just pay it forward, be
able to speak about it
- For sure.
- has been amazing.
I think, honestly, sharing
your story not only empowers
yourself, but is a way of
paying it forward for others.
I always say nothing haunts us
like the things we don't say.
You have to leave it out there.
You have to expose
it in some way.
I'm not saying you
have to do it publicly,
but it's amazing how
freeing that can be.
- The game is, "Do You
Know Your Best Friend?"
- You’re not my best friend.
- Kevin, what is my
favorite city to play in?
I'll be honest, I
don't even know what—
- Phoenix?
- Top three.
OK.
One.
[Ding]
- Do you like Chicago?
- No.
- Do you like New York City?
- This is not how the game works.
- OK. OK.
- So Phoenix—
Phoenix, New York.
[Ding]
Can't say Cleveland.
It's too obvious.
Los Angeles?
[Ding]
- Yeah.
Boom.
- Channing Frye, what
breed of dog do I have?
- Oh, Vestry is a Vizsla.
[Ding]
- There you go.
- I hate that fucking dog.
What is the one thing
that makes a good party?
- A cheese platter.
- A fucking cheese platter.
- Got to hit it right.
- If it is not local
sourced honey,
I'm not fucking with you.
- It's got to be the bee's knees.
Are we hearing that
in the background?
What is my pregame ritual?
- Oh.
- This is impossible to—
- You drink your beet juice.
You take your little
peanut butter jelly thing.
You get rid of
everything that's sweaty.
You go through six pairs of
socks, two jerseys, two pants.
You switch all your stuff
up because you're sweating.
You used to do these
stretches and these stretches
for at least 20 minutes.
- ELDOA stretches.
- ELDOs?
- ELDOA.
- ELDOA stretches?
- Yeah.
- So yes or no?
Am I right or wrong?
- Put some ‘speck on my name.
- Kevin, how old are my kids?
Oh, my God.
Hendrix is 11.
- 10.
[Buzzer]
Close.
- Margaux is seven.
- Nine.
[Buzzer]
Close.
- Roxie is—
- Four?
[Ding]
- Yup.
- OK.
- Lennox is—
- Three?
[Ding]
- Yep.
Shaniqua is—
- Shut up.
- OK.
- What is a niche item
that I love to collect?
- Ooh.
- This is, like,
three separate things.
So if you get even one of
them, I'd be surprised.
- Don't you have a Navajo
rug in your house?
- Oh, yeah.
That's actually—
- One.
[Ding]
- Yeah.
- And No. 2 would
be trading cards.
[Ding]
- And No. 3 would be—
- Vintage patches.
I know you like patches.
I didn't know that
they were vintage.
- No, but the rugs and stuff,
that was pretty impressive.
- Right.
I have a very good memory
about things that don't matter.
What is my favorite
thing to order to eat?
- Shit.
I don't know.
- So if I had to eat one food
forever, what would it be?
- One food…
[Buzzer]
- It's a burrito. But good try.
- Oh, 100 percent.
How I missed that,
I'll never know.
You can wrap anything—
- What is one food that I hate?
- Oh, cucumbers.
[Ding]
You're allergic.
Kevin, this seems like—
- Oh, my God.
My bad.
- Where was Chosen's
first bottle made?
- Dundee Hills?
[Ding]
- Wow.
You even went with
the AVA, but yes.
L'Angolo Estate, Dundee Hills.
Go ahead.
Oh, that was the last question.
Thank you guys for
another episode.
This has been amazing
to say the least.
I'm glad we could
do it in person.
My BFFFF Kevin Love.
- Which means I'm fourth in line.
- Thank you for—
yeah, a lot of F's.
Thank you for coming
to “Full-Bodied.”
♪♪♪
- How did you scam your
way into this show?
- I'm fucking Channing Frye.
[Laughing]